you
this year's Oscars weekend movies
biggest night of the year
the awards as usual will be given out in
Hollywood that hasn't changed but
Hollywood itself has changed
dramatically and that is the focus of a
new book just out it is called the big
goodbye and it explores the end of an
era in Hollywood a change that gave us
the Hollywood we have today through the
lens of a watershed film Chinatown
listen pal an honest living people only
come to me when they're in a desperate
situation I help them out I don't keep
families out of their houses like these
bums down at the bank Jay from its
earliest scenes it's clear Chinatown is
more than a place it's a metaphor for
the futility of good intentions in this
case for a private detective named Jacob
Geddes played by Jack Nicholson this
business requires a certain amount of
finesse Nicholson then the cool prints
of a Hollywood system that was about to
come crashing down very queer why is it
the big goodbye it's the big goodbye to
a Hollywood that made by and large a
great product for over a decade Sam
Lawson has been writing about Hollywood
in the film business his 2010 bestseller
Fifth Avenue 5:00 a.m. told the story of
Audrey Hepburn in Breakfast at Tiffany's
he is now the author of the big goodbye
it's the big goodbye to an America
before Watergate in America before
Vietnam so it's a big goodbye to
innocence said in 1937 the corruption at
the center of Chinatown is inspired by
real events from the early 1900s when
powerful city officials and businessmen
seeking water for rapidly growing Los
Angeles obtained rights from poor rural
farmers
the movie focuses on Nicholson's
character who stumbles onto a similar
scheme involving a wealthy businessman
played by John Huston you may think you
know what you do but believe me you
don't and Faye Dunaway as a classic
femme fatale with a twist I don't know
what you were talking about Paul Koch
was Chinatown's assistant director and a
source for Watson did you know at the
time something special was happening oh
yeah the script was great and we were
all excited and we had the best of the
best in every department the movie was
written by Robert Towne and is
considered by many to be the greatest
script in film history and won the Oscar
for Best Original Screenplay in 1975
conceived at the height of Watergate the
story neared reality the more Geddes
digs for the truth the more darkness he
finds at every turn did it ever get any
better than this I don't know if it got
better it got different Watson writes
that Koch in town were part of a team
that made Chinatown during its time when
Hollywood was drastically more
storyteller friendly before blockbusters
sequels prequels and tie-ins nowhere was
that more apparent than at Paramount run
at the time by legendary producer Robert
Evans when he first got the script for
Chinatown it didn't make any sense to
him it was incomprehensible but he bet
on it because it was a Robert Towne
script and Robert Towne meant Talent
he said I don't know what this is about
but you guys I trust ya so go do it yeah
I mean if you're gonna hire Picasso are
you gonna micromanage Picasso are you
gonna say oh maybe you should use a
little blue Pablo here
no no JJ get us to see mr. Mulwray then
at the peak of his powers Jack Nicholson
is in every scene of Chinatown but kaca
is one of the most important parts about
Nicholson was the environment he
cultivated off-screen it was his
personality that just came across and
you you fall in love with him Jack had
that smile and that sparkle in his eye
that you you want to be around him the
other essential player in Chinatown was
the director Roman Polanski
so has a cameo in the film yeah very
nosy fellow kittycat huh you know what
happens to nosy fellas
they lose their noses next time you lose
the whole thing
this was Polanski's first film in
Hollywood since his pregnant wife Sharon
Tate was murdered by Charles Manson's
followers in 1969
three years after Chinatown's release
Polanski was charged with drugging and
sexually assaulting a 13 year old girl
he pled guilty to a lesser crime of sex
with a minor but fled the country before
sentencing I think it's impossible for a
lot of people to have any discussion of
Polanski the filmmaker given what
happened I would encourage people as a
lover of film and a someone who believes
Polanski's may be our greatest living
filmmaker I would encourage those people
to look at the work and and hopefully be
able to hold both truths in their hearts
and minds that he did this horrible
thing and made these beautiful films
reality includes both in relatively
short order after Chinatown came out
Polanski was out of the country Bob
Evans was out at Paramount Robert Towne
began battling drug issues that may have
prevented him from ever writing the same
way again
and a landmark Hollywood movie arrived
you're gonna need a bigger potion
jaws the original blockbuster that's a
20-footer 25 you see a lot of money that
would normally be allocated for
production not going on the screen but
going into marketing campaigns the
actual artistic component becomes less
and less and less important to the
bottom line and that's given way to the
world that we have now it's a sad book
it's a sad book it's not I disagree like
that well thank you for saying I
disagree I think it's it's energizing to
read about something that someone's
passionate about well thank you I think
and that doesn't mean it's sad and
you're right you have to be passionate
in order to be sad you have to love
something you know and if losing it
means anything and that's what Chinatown
is I mean Chinatown is loving something
and losing something
wasun has a grim view of whether today's
Hollywood can ever produce original
movies like it did in the early 1970s
Hawke Koch is a little more hopeful
coulda movie like this we made today boy
I hope so I would hope so there are
still people in our town that want to
make really good stories we're
storytellers
I'm very proud to have been part of this
film very proud yeah okay against China
Town
[Music]
that famous final line we should be
clear salmon Hawker not saying that
great movies aren't being made today
they just say a lot of them aren't
coming out of that Hollywood system the
Independent System and said seems to
take some of them right coming from
other places movies like parasite for
example and that's how Harvey Weinstein
made his you know made his name because
he knew how to market films in a
situation a lot of people are saying you
know maybe some of those films that were
well marketed didn't deserve some of
these yeah ask her attention that they
received anyway Sam Watson does a
wonderful job with this book it's again
it's called the big goodbye just a great
job beautiful meticulously research
bringing everything together inside one
book and that end of end of the arrow
great interview yeah